[Music]
I'm going to Tokyo I'm gonna Tokyo I'm
going to Tokyo I got a pack
putting Tamar everyone I am in Tokyo for
Pokemon detective Pikachu and I'm ready
to see everything that Tokyo has to
offer from the food to the culture to
the language and maybe whole system on
the line along the way I'm on a boat let
me get you detective
we are here in Akihabara and I already
see some anime some mangas I got a
pickup a manga for my friend and also I
heard that there's some Pokemon in this
store so let's go check it out
[Music]
they want to be on the wrong tonight
thank you for getting the traffic of
opposite even when walking I'm like a
little overwhelmed there's so much I
went to a stand that sold
taiyaki which is a thin waffle but on
the inside it has the sweet red bean
paste and my taste buds were like what
is this we've never had this before but
they're very satisfied as I was walking
chillin looking at all the things
something caught my eye look what I
found
it's melon I want to say fun because
that's how you say it in Spanish but
doesn't it look good a fun job oh my god
should we try it
look oh it was so cool being on the
other side of the world and finding a
piece of my culture here in Tokyo who's
tripping me out then we went to go meet
justice and Catherine from the movie and
I think totally geeked out
[Music]
can we take a selfie so I don't know if
you guys just saw that chemistry there
but I'm pretty sure we became best
friends and like I think they like want
me to be in the next movie so yeah later
that night we went on a dinner cruise I
was so excited and then all of a sudden
Ryan Reynolds comes down from the boat
and takes a picture with us it felt like
such a nerd because I was like oh
Pikachu and it was madness there was a
ton of food a cute Pikachu shaped cake
and karaoke I sing all the time on my
socials so I was here in Japan which is
the home of karaoke I had to do it
maybe I brought down the house a little
bit no no after a busy day we came to
hapa when to Zen out a little bit we got
to make some origami Pikachu's then we
got to make our own sushi sushi baby I
did it I explored the wonderful world of
detective Pikachu I walked around a
bunch had an amazing experience at
different stores ate a bunch of great
food made some origami sushi wow I did a
lot thank you so much Warner Brothers go
see Pokemon detective Pikachu in
theaters May 10th
[Music]